okay so we've looked into Claudius
before right we actually spent a whole
topic on it a whole department confusing
topic for many people we're going to try
and fold it into induction as well
personally I find what the way I'm
trying to do this is we've looked at
these different categories of induction
proofs right so we've looked at say um
for series we started off with nice TV
series that we know how to deal with
already
we looked at some algebraic identities
which are a little meaner but they still
have that hard to do and then what do we
be doing more recently I'm Suffolk
factorials in it and divisibility more
recently okay I've been going through
them in the order where I think they
become more complex or more even more
complex we have to think harder it's
less it's less for the formulaic you
can't just go through the steps and
machine it out you've actually got to
think as you go through it okay and I
think this is a good example so let's
begin here's a new sound our first one I
think it's through to the air
okay so this is what we're required to
prove okay let's see
I do you know well enough now that I
don't have to write it down we're our 4
steps we want to test for the first law
they assume that it's true for a
particular value k prove that is true
for the next value if you can assume
that's true for K and then you just
conclude with your explanation okay
so let's give it a go shall we what is
the first allowable value what do you
think look at it hmm
any watch for 0 doesn't it um it doesn't
work for actually doesn't work for
negative numbers it does work for any
numbers that's interesting other side 0
I didn't specify but usually it will be
0 and on if you can get 0 right so 0 is
kind of like the best case but sometimes
it breaks things there because we have
that in that equality in the inequality
we can use 0 so it's going to go yeah
usually you start off by saying left
hand side equals this and the right hand
side equation that's fine
okay for inequalities I'm going to start
with the right hand side hopefully
you'll become clear in a second why even
though that might seem backwards to you
at first okay the right hand side is
equal to 1 plus 2 lots of 0 which is 1
so now I can look at the left hand side
which is 3 to the power of 0 which is 1
and now what do I do here I don't say
equals the right hand side even though
in this case it actually does write
these numbers could be different and it
would still satisfy the statement right
so instead I'm going to take my
inequality from here right so I'll say 1
right well that is greater than or equal
to the right hand side does satisfy it
right you see why I did the right hand
side first now because now this final
statement here is the left is on the
left and the right
right okay if you did the left-hand side
first you can have right hand side here
and you'll be like right hand side left
hand side and your inequality will be
backwards and it's this is confusing
just have it left on the left right on
the right okay there's the test now in
your soup
so just straight substitution okay
also don't forget to mention what K is
right so I guess we'd say K must be a
positive integer like we just noticed I
think it does work for negatives but for
now since I'm starting from zero and I'm
going to go all the way forward I'm just
going to say K can be anything forward
from do okay all right so now my proof
okay
prove what am i required to prove for k
plus 1 right so I've got three the power
of K plus 1 should be greater than or
equal to is going to be 2 k plus 3 right
okay now usually when we've been proving
these you sort of start with this line
and then you sort of twist it and
manipulate it around until you can get
something which will let you sub in your
assumption okay I think you can do that
but with inequalities I think it will
feel more logical if you actually start
with your assumption is your very first
line okay so I'm going to say by
assumption right at the beginning 3 to
the K is very equal to 1 plus okay okay
and now I'm going to try and twist the
term this to get into my proof okay so
what do you think is the easiest step
what I want to do what's the most
natural thing to get from this line to
that one you can kill the other side
right I haven't tried the right-hand
side so I went for the left straight
away because I see the left first so to
get from here to here I have to multiply
by three right that's what the plus one
is okay so all multiplied by three so
I've got multiply this side by three
also okay now I've got my left-hand side
nice now over here let me just um switch
the order around a little bit
I've got six k plus three okay now
here's where I mean that um inequalities
will force you to just think a little
more okay this is not that it's not what
we were setting out to prove at least it
wasn't exactly right but it's enough
isn't it you see what's happening okay
right okay excuse me
here's a positive integer at least
that's the way I've specified right so
if it's positive then surely 6 K will be
bigger than 2 K yeah 6 K is bigger than
2 K right so they go there's a reason
why K as a negative 1
for at least this method of proof now 6k
is bigger than 2 K and 3 to the k plus 1
is bigger than that right
so surely 3 to the k plus 1 must also be
bigger than this right so I would say
since K is positive right you can put on
the site here I don't think this bit is
necessary but it's helpful for your
watching I think therefore 6 K is
greater than 2 K right so I'm just
making the connection between what I
have and what I have in my what I need
to prove ok so seeing a 6 training is
rather than 2 K because this is an
inequality I can just shift things
around like I can say 3 K plus 1 is
greater than 2 K what's 3 this implies
this right it's just like saying if if a
number is greater than 10 then surely
it's also greater than 5
that's all I'm doing ok this implies
that and that's in ok maybe you didn't
think that was hardly for those were an
obvious okay but I know when I was
getting through this topic myself going
from here to here is kind of you get
this point you think huh I don't hear
there well that is yeah ok that's it
pressure so by the principle of
mathematical induction
oh my last step you see this zero sorry
ok ok so um
that seems ok let's let's have a go at
another time briefly which instead of
it's got a tricky numbers in there okay
so instead of just a multiplication it's
very easy to do with okay let's throw a
factorial
so it happens so that sounds that's over
here
let's do it in a new color
okay I think I mentioned before right
that a lot of these more advanced
inequality proofs right they will not
work for 0 1 2 3 4 5 internet no right
they will actually only start working it
quite large values okay
so here's an example right there for my
first allowable value you actually have
to use your brain oh they got this one
is 5 so I'm still dealing with integers
right induction deals with interviews so
instead of N equals 0 I'm going to start
with 5 okay now again because of the way
the inequality is going to work out I'm
going to start with the right-hand side
so I'm just going to get rid of all this
okay
the right-hand side is 2 to 5 which is
32 and the left-hand side is 5 factorial
which is a hundred and twenty okay and
120 is greater than the right hand side
for 32 that we got before therefore the
left hand side and right hand side so
it's true for the first allowable case
okay that was the test here's the
assumption
now by the way because n has to follow
certain rules right namely it's rather
than 4 and K is a particular kind of air
than cares to obey the same rules as
well right so K must be greater
therefore and this will turn out to be
crucial for us later but later on okay
excuse me now what we have to prove k
plus 1 factorial greater than okay now
again with these inequalities I think
the easiest way to do is logical way to
get to the N is to actually start with
your assumption so by assumption K
factorial
greater than
excuse me where do you go from there
I can said before you could go for
either side in this case I think the
left-hand side
conveniently is still the easiest to
Madrid okay so if I would turn K
factorial into K + 1 factorial what do I
have to multiply by yeah just the next
one in the end we multiply both sides
okay now on the left hand side I'm set
on the right hand side you look at what
you've got and you look at what you're
supposed to have now what's the
difference between 2 k plus 1 and 2 the
K they're different by a factor of 2
right so if I could multiply this by 2 I
get what I want right now multiplied by
something a multiple my cables 1 now it
just like in the previous question
multiplying by K plus 1 is not just
multiplying by twos actually it's better
than multiplying by 2 isn't it because
if you're multiplying by K plus 1 then
you're multiplying by at least 5 see it
right that's the smallest value that it
can take and that's why we already
tested it right
so therefore right I can say but right K
plus 1 this thing that I've gotten here
right I could say it's greater than 5
from here but all I really need is that
it's greater than 2 right because I'm
going to substitute that for a 2 so k
plus 1 factorial is greater than 2 times
2 to the K again people seem
uncomfortable about this because like
all you're substituting stuff but that's
cable ties not equal to okay that's true
k plus 1 is better than two
do you see why you can just chop and
change things when you've got you
these okay and that's where my to to the
catastrophic
now don't forget again the statement is
true for what so you go back to your
original question and they gave you the
domain for it right and it's great at
the full factorial yeah it does but
before that's weird why would they
anyway doesn't matter maybe I read the
question rolling those meant to be a
quality day yeah
same I do okay the key thing the tricky
thing I think okay is making sure you
get one of the sides looking just like
you want it and then working out how
you're going to twist the other side so
you get what you need